well hey let's bring in the other the
other judges that know this is keeping
you and I'm happy wait to bring them
Emmitt waiting I'm not ready
[Music]
you want to know honestly what I'm doing
fun feeling I don't want to see it you
inspired me Simon that you were able
well here's what it is Terry Crews is
the consummate host good friend and
everything what is he known for besides
hosting our show having huge pants able
to control them right and you can do it
now till right I can do it now as well
yeah you know when you get one of these
really bad auditions on the show and all
you're thinking is how quickly can they
get you off the stage yes means hey
Sophia how you doing Heidi that gosh
that I make up I'm in love with that is
amazing he's on the other side to flip
this Greek yeah there's a lot of us is a
large zoom call please welcome Howie
Mandel Heidi Klum Sofia Vergara and the
host of AGT Terry Crews right y'all so
I'm gonna start with Howie naked boy
number one have the rest of these guys
apologize for not taking her
about germs seriously oh my gosh no no I
told him this is some people call it a
pandemic I call it toldja
no they haven't apologized I don't want
an apology I mean you know all kidding
aside you know I booked enough
everything this is the nightmare I've
lived in my own mind the last 64 years
of my life and now every I was nice to
wake up and find out it was only a
nightmare now every day I'm waking up
and finding out you're all in the
nightmare with me her hair I'm just like
what okay
oh here actually that's kind of a good
segue because you had your own co-ed
scare right you're doing well now right
I'm fine I never had it but you know at
the time when you know just kind of hit
America and when it hit Los Angeles I
all of a sudden got sick I came to set
and I had a fever I had a cough I wasn't
feeling good you know when you have your
body ache everywhere and I got there and
I told you know someone immediately I
was like I'm not feeling good and you
know there's this Korona thing going
around and immediately they had the
medic they're coming to you know see how
high my fever was and they dismissed me
immediately and send me home and
thankfully I never had it and um yeah we
did I guess everyone did the right thing
for sending me home but that's why you
know arrey got to come and sit in my
seat which was I'm sure so much fun by
the way Sofia was thrilled it was very
strange to leave because you know I'm
very German I'm always very on time I do
as I'm told and I've never really been
sick and been sent home so I felt so
bizarre but it was like you know such a
blow honestly I've never told you this
offensive look I think she should leave
for the whole season
but you still found a socially distant
way to get your hair done and I just
want to say I mean I have to tell you
you know we have someone in the family
who has from the very beginning like not
going out like washing everything
because when you have someone around you
with an autoimmune disease it's like
extra on high alert so I never really
have really seen anybody done anywhere
I've done anything but you know we were
like okay we have to do the super proper
you know with the umbrella we have all
the masks on and everything just tell
the highlights I mean I did all the
washing and everything else but he just
came by and did a few highlights because
I'm not a real blonde you know what I'm
saying so it was like I hear you on the
how do you mean think that's why I was
so scared I have an autoimmune disease
so I was like what and I freaked out so
I feel you on that and I love the photo
I mean forgive me umbrella no one's
looking at the damn umbrella was rocking
with Julie Sophie ahead I'll be walking
around naked and a frozen food you
t'think God had great weight Sophia so
is it true your husband this is like one
of my favorite things your husband Joe
holds a Dungeons & Dragons club in your
house I mean these photos and I actually
once I heard about this actually do you
play do you play this I want to I was
I'm such a nerd alert
like I literally went down a little
rabbit hole of like watching it on
YouTube like him talking about who's
come in and out of the game and it's
like the most random group of people so
this is super weird they're really weird
hearing the house I mean now now that
they are in quarantine they're doing it
on soon
they have still been playing it's crazy
because they couldn't do something this
game for like six seven hours and they
sing they clap they I don't know what
they're doing down there it's like a
something really weird that I can't
understand but it sounds fun
you know most people who play Dungeons
and Dragons don't even meet pretty girls
to marry one you ended up with the guy
that plays done complete nerd I always
tell him that he's trusting the wrong
looks like a man's club it looks like
Rascals like women aren't invited know
that they're being girls playing here I
mean it's a percentage but yes they do
come and play okay so wait Hallie you
you just act you just actually
celebrated your 40th wedding anniversary
in lockdown she'll do anything special
because I remember your birthday you
brought an elephant in for her so for
her birthday did I do anything special
yes I took her to the guest room
[Laughter]
were you christening the house or what's
happening we've written that we've been
here for years and decades and decades
you know in quarantine
she wasn't not there were no surprises
it's just we said we want to redo our
vows and she came up with one vow and
then her vow was enough already
Sophia you're the judge so what kind of
Acts are you liking what are you digging
about the show you know what I mean I
was having such a great time we had to
stop because of all
no the virus situation but I was having
such a great time I mean it was like
better that I thought he was gonna be I
you know I loved everybody I think we
all have gotten along from the beginning
there being there in this page the
contestants everything it's I mean I am
very lucky to be part of this group now
oh that's cool I know I love that's what
I love about being part of the voice I
just I love when I love going to work
you know you love when you love going
everybody's cool voice oh wait but we're
not even on at the same time it doesn't
matter it's still kind of competition so
bad things about it okay okay good
answer good answer
and the mother reassure yourself
everything will be all right as you stay
off Sand River to the south
what they did today is move me to this
point
right now hey y'all I'm back with the
team of America's Got Talent Simon
Cowell Howie Mandel Heidi Klum Sofia
Vergara and Terry Crews
alright so Terry you use your golden
buzzer for the voices of our city choir
um what did you love about them oh my
god first of all the fact that you know
here we had a homeless choir who came up
from San Diego they wrote their own
music they did their own things
it was absolutely it just it moved me
beyond belief I was in tears and I knew
as soon as I saw them that I had to give
I just rushed the stage because the
opportunity that each one of these you
know men and women took was a risk you
know they've been cast away they've been
you know marginalized for so long
and to get the confidence to get up
there and try something like this I had
to reward them and let me tell you they
were outstanding I'm one of my best best
things I've ever done in my life
and it's just it's like that for all our
golden buzzers I love the golden buzzer
well Heidi who did you pick for your
golden buzzer - for Christina Rey she's
a singer I fell in love with her
immediately and I mean she also has the
most heart-wrenching story but you know
I always go with my gut instinct and you
know I just loved her and I loved her
performance I love to have voice and I
don't know maybe it's gonna be my golden
buzzer I was going to win it all this
time Kari technically I think she might
be one of the best singers ever had on
the show really yeah honest to god I
mean have you watched that movie 20 feet
from stardom
yeah with darling love oh yeah you know
those great singers she hasn't been
given a shot yet I mean her voice is off
the chart this girl that's exciting I
love here and just I love people in
their element just really nailing it and
what they do but so well hello Simon how
did you use your
well I actually gave my golden buzzer to
some dances and I love I'm not a dongs
expert believe it or not you know it's
like Terry was saying you know their
story often has a lot to do in there and
they were setting about these guys and
they were talking to me and I could see
how much it meant to them and then I was
speeding Lots the audience and you don't
think about it in the moment it's just
like you just want to give them that
extra boost I got a feeling that they
might be in the top three at the end
these guys okay mines the only one that
hasn't aired yet and I got to tell you
something I've been on the show and I
keep mentioning this ad nauseam for like
11 years this is the first time that I
press the golden buzzer for something
that has never graced the stages of AGT
it's not a singer it's not a magician
it's not a dancer it's not music it's
something you've never seen on a GPS
with a court I don't sleep Howie I've
seen it in the cards yeah yeah this this
person is phenomenal it's even better
now the worst teams I'm like okay cool I
got to wait so wait still fear this was
your first time user golden buzzer who
is your sport
it was super exciting because he was on
my first day I don't even know why I had
the feeling that I needed to do that it
was for reverse of Italian she's a ten
year old girl she was amazing and you
know what when I after I've been
watching the show I still really think
that he was it was the perfect choice
right guys super super talented you know
you spend a lot of time in the UK but
Kelly Clarkson was also a singer who was
discovered on a show must have been
amazing he nailed it they nailed it all
right well speaking of judges in the
judges cuts episodes you're together for
the first time how great is that well
you know what we're going into unknown
territory here Kelly so this is I swear
when I say we are making this out day by
day we are making this out day by day
but I've got to hand it to everyone on
the call here everyone's embraced it
everyone's contributed ideas number one
priority keep saying second priority get
the contestants to be amazing subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going